so today we're going to look primarily
at arguments for God's existence in
Dakar and I've switched around material
a little bit so that we're looking at
some stuff again from chapter meditation
one a lot of stuff of meditation three
and then some stuff from meditation five
the reason that we're doing that is
because those are the areas where the
card actually talks about God's
existence and we've talked quite a bit
this semester when we looked at the
Anselm and Thomas Aquinas and even a
little bit with Aristotle about his
notion of God and a very metaphysical
it's got something we didn't prove but
of God in terms of the highest being or
necessary being or the creator clause of
everything the ultimate clause the prime
mover orderer of all things those are
all men of metaphysical concepts of God
you wouldn't actually have to be a
Christian Jew or Muslim but committed to
any particular religion in order to hold
a philosophical idea like that and then
earlier this semester I asked you again
we talked a bit about this why would
people want to prove the existence of
God there and believe in God and some of
that was possibly due to wanting to
convince other people or maybe not being
quite sure oneself or being a way to get
myself culture in some way to God to
figure out God's attributes the curtain
is doing something a little bit
different and I start the class actually
with this quote from another philosopher
time period as Descartes he was a
contemporary of Descartes his name is
down here blaze Hospital and we're not
going to be meeting him simply we don't
have enough time in the semester but
we're going to read somebody who's kind
of like him interviews about God and
about philosophy and that's Kierkegaard
we're gonna read to Kierkegaard towards
the end of the class yeah she had this
to say about about God and about dick
Hardison I cannot forget Descartes in
all his philosophy he did his best to
dispense with God but he could not avoid
making him set the world in motion after
that he had no more use forgotten and I
think that that's pretty accurate when
it comes to what Descartes is doing with
God and why Descartes has these proofs
for God's existence the card is not
somebody like Ansel who's interested in
God for God's own sake to try to you
know know what this infinite or eternal
substance yes he's not a monk he is if
anything a scientist if you look at the
material I put an ayah where you realize
that you've already learned some things
back in algebra class that Descartes
came up with like Cartesian coordinates
XY plane Descartes also made a lot of
contributions in other areas of
mathematics Andy made contributions in
terms of physics something that you'd
actually study today because physics has
progressed beyond him but he did make
important contributions that got us on
the way to where we are today
and his way of looking at things his way
of treating things separating the mind
from the body that's been very
influential treating everything in terms
of everything physical in terms of
mechanism that was very nice remember
pretty current our bodies are just
machines machines that somehow our soul
connects our mind connects up with them
it's very difficult to explain
but you never truly succeeded with but
you know that's that's a tricky problem
so why is dick heart bringing God in you
might say specific heart is a a devout
committed Christian that appears that he
went to church every once in a while but
he doesn't you don't seem to have gotten
an awful lot out of it he actually was a
mercenary during the Wars of Religion
that were being fought in Germany thirty
years war between Catholics and
Protestants with France taking a rather
opportunistic you know side of history
and he didn't seem to really care much
about that either you lived most of his
life when he could in Holland which was
not a Catholic country he was you know
supposedly a Roman Catholic but he chose
to live in a place where he more or less
avoid religious problems so why is he
bringing Gotham
well that's what we're gonna look at
today and it it comes into his
philosophy for a very important reason
the current thinks that if you can't
count on some sort of idea of God that
once you've gone this way you're going
to methodological doubt like we did in
the first two meditations stopping
everything saying maybe there's an evil
demon that's deceiving me once you start
doing that you want to try to find your
way back out of it if you don't have God
in the picture not a guy who like you
know comes and saves humanity or wants
you to have a church on Sundays or
anything like that but some sort of
metaphysical concept of God if you don't
have something like that you can't ever
be certain about anything other than
that you exist so let's let's do a
little bit of review first right the
current started out talking about these
doubts you know we get to see sometimes
by some people brought up why
we talk about hallucinations or or some
other ways I'm going to see mirages
right so you know that you're sensing
you're not entirely reliable you've all
experienced that sort of deception as a
matter of fact we routinely experience
it we talked about this filming you know
what are we doing when were filming
we're actually creating an illusion
whoever's watching this video it's as if
they're there in the classroom with you
although you know you know they're not
some of these videos there have been
something like 450 views and there's
only 25 scenes in the classroom roughly
so there's an illusion
so what else dreams right every night
those of you who dream I had a dream
last night actually it was a terrible
trip that I've been handed to a werewolf
and I woke up from that and I was very
happy that I did indeed do it it wasn't
just like an ordinary Hollywood werewolf
this thing was like 12 feet tall you
know driving along and the cops would
like cordoned off an area and for some
reason I get out of my car and I'm
walking and then I stop please sniper
team you know I'm thinking well that's
chemistry and r1 or third but they're
doing out here let as I walked I
realized what they were actually you
know it's supposed to shoot is that the
werewolf or Japanese well you know none
of that happens thank God right but it
seemed very real and I'm willing to bet
that most of you dreamed last night
right can you dream about something
either very good and you kind of wish it
after you woke up you could get back to
that dream where you dreamed about
something bad yeah you were very happy
that wasn't real you may have even
dreamed about being in this classroom
taking a class you may have dreamed
about writing a paper and you wrote this
really great research paper and then you
woke up and then you realize oh it was
only a dream I had to do all that work
over again have you ever done have a
dream like that we talked about dreams
where you go to work and you put in a
full day and you wake up from it you're
bad because now you you worms you
actually did work in your dream in that
sort of reality but you didn't dream in
the outside reality where you'll
actually get paid for punching you know
putting in eight hours
how can you tell where the dreams are
real enough I mean right now you all
think that you're awake right hopefully
this isn't just a dream
I have to teach this again when I wake
up for men even better would be this if
this was a dream and I've already taught
this and I won't have to you know reach
the lesson but that's not gonna that's
not gonna happen we think this is waking
reality right how do we tell Descartes
didn't give us any science for figuring
that up in meditation and study actually
just went deeper said well you know at
least some dreams we can count on
mathematics and kind of the laws of
logic but could we doubt those two turns
out yeah could be that there's some sort
of evil genius out there that screws you
up every time that you try to do
mathematics and 2+2 week doesn't
actually equal 4 equals 5 that's just
that every time you start counting you
know there's a little sleight of hand
that gets pulled and you never know is
maybe you don't have any body maybe you
never had a body we talked about all
these you know sort of movies right
remember Dark City or the matrix or
Inception maybe you're not actually a
human being maybe you're actually a
program in some sort of computer that
thinks it's a human being because you
were programmed to think that Chris take
Kurt doesn't think about this sort of
stuff but that one that would fit in
with this evil genius hypothesis if
somebody else created a world in which
you would exist how would you know if
any of you ever get the chance to watch
the 13th floor that one actually deals
with that they are there and there's a
world in which people that have likes is
somewhere in California and they're
working on these computer projects to
create a virtual reality you know you
know relatively familiar with
reality then if you play the sims or any
first-person shooter games or those
other kind of first-person games I need
to play those loaded virtual reality
right it's it's not as if you completely
lose yourself in it unless you there's
something wrong that doesn't happen to
some people but imagine it could be made
even more extensive so those are those
characters in the game think that
they're real yeah
there wouldn't be very good characters
if they didn't how do you know you're
not a character like that it's some sort
of game that's always agree you could be
use that conception will be how do you
know when you're not a little stock
characters in somebody else's dream can
you prove it well the Kurt doesn't deal
with that so much but he does deal with
this idea of you know being without a
body and having all these sensations
being given to him by some evil deceiver
and he he says that I can be one I can
be sure one thing that I exist so you
know even if you're a program or a
figment of somebody's imagination you
exist as soon as you can start
questioning whether you exist or not you
exist because who's doing the
questioning if you can be deceived and
think you're something other than what
you are you exist right and what do you
exist as what do you remember he said we
are
without our bodies right
thinking substance a thing that thinks
right substance means you you exist over
time you knew last there's something
real error and you are you are thought
you are your your memories your
imaginations your intellect your will
all these sorts of things that's you
you're not your body so you'll stop and
think about what this means for that how
old are you guys
is anybody here not 18 besides me of
course strange that happens you should
probably ask for your money back because
they couldn't possibly know you're 18
okay that works you did you can count
right so if you're 18 what year were you
guys born 3 do you remember being born
many of you remember being born then any
reason I remember like being 1 year old
two-year-old three-year-old you remember
being 4 but most people remember about
that far back I remember some vague
stuff about three years old and
everything before that's some people
thing to remember you don't like when
they are one but they're actually
remembering anything out of a sort of
imagination how do you know your
memories are actually real maybe they
were implanted in your head maybe you
only started to exist yesterday can't be
completely sure of a canyon anymore than
you can be completely sure that I'm not
say a robot of some sort and almost you
cut me open but you can't be sure about
is the things that pertain to thought
that part of it some of you are
abandoned some of you are women right
that's just your body there's no gender
to a soul started to cart goes or to a
mind that's just part of your body your
height your weight
I'll strong your body is skin color hair
color eye color all those sorts of
things those are purely bodily that's
not really who you are we're gonna take
hard what you really are is a thing that
thinks and that body of yours but you
don't be happy that you've got it right
because they play 18 year old bodies are
a lot better than four year old bodies
that's just sort of like a car that
you're driving around and you know
theoretically you could put that that
mind into another body and it would
really make much difference but we know
we're sensing things though right you're
you're hearing me right now you're
seeing me how do you know that that's
real that's you know that you actually
have those sensations do you know they
correspond to something real I mean you
could say well you know this is solid
well sure but if this was a dream it
would something like that to where this
is some sort of computer-generated
reality of it something like that as
well or if there was an evil genius you
know setting things up to fool you if he
wouldn't Rasheed or it would make things
out like that as well so you can you can
trust that you actually have sensations
that you have memories but at this point
you can't actually trust that they give
you the real story
so this is where meditation three begins
and Descartes is going to say well let's
let's think about the origins of our
ideas let's think about the different
parts of our mind so worth we're a thing
that thinks what does that mean
one of the different ways in which you
think well you know that you have sense
impressions or sense data right like to
hearing me right now how like the the
computer in front of most of you like
the sensation of your clothes on you
like the feeling that you have was
sitting in a desk
all of those are sense data that's
coming to the you know you're looking at
me some of you some of you're looking at
computers things are coming into your
your perception you're perceiving things
you don't actually know that those
things truly exist or that they are the
way that you think that they are yet but
you certainly are perceiving things and
if I say what's the movie that came out
of any of you seen any movies recently
watch new movies nobody let me get out
watch anything what if we get seen on TV
lately oh is helloween recently right
it's seen any scary movies what's scary
monster what's that oh that's a good one
that looks really scary you saw the
number three one or the first okay yeah
those look really scary apart and those
deal with that that that issue of like
seeing things on a camera and can you be
sure that they're real or not they're
exploring some some fairly Cartesian
themes
okay so ghost write our ghosts real or
not we're not they've worked artisans at
this probably say I don't know I don't
have to evidence one way or the other
what did the ghost look like internal
paranormal activity
okay there's no like screenshot where
you actually like see them full-on or
anything that makes it scarier when you
can't actually see what's going on okay
so imagine a a hostile entity that you
can't actually see and screw up your
life and all bunch of different ways now
if you actually see it anything like
that is that part of your memory
hopefully none of you came in contact
with some sort of paranormal activity at
one point when in which case it would be
memory and memory is of things that you
actually did in fact see right you were
calling yourself data backups mine what
else you know you can use your
imagination
you can take your things that you've
seen and heard and all that and
rearrange them put them together how
many have you ever seen a unicorn and I
don't mean just like a coasters you know
or keychains or stuff like that
I even never seen you ever in real life
Oh Kenny it's possible right I mean
somebody could make me run I suppose you
can get a horse and you know cut some
hair here and glue a horn on to its head
and say there's a unicorn or maybe do
some genetic modification but all of you
can imagine a unicorn right what do you
how do you do that well you take the
image of horse I may take the image of
horn and you stick them together now
imagine a blue unicorn can you do that
now imagine it with wings combined the
Pegasus everyone able to do that you've
never seen anything like that but what
you've done is you've combined images
and bits of them together now imagine
and it doesn't always have to be sense
data it could be other things too now an
imagine you
or who loves you can you imagine that
what would that be like how are unicorns
show its love for you what do you think
you'd have to imagine it on you know
it's some sort of analogy to something
else and if you have dogs or cats or
ferrets imagine it like that now imagine
a unicorn that hates your guts and every
time it sees you it gets angry better
watch out for that horn right you can do
that you're taking ideas and you're
putting them together that's an activity
of your mind
that's not something that your body is
doing that's something that your mind is
doing in addition of that these are the
lower faculties we also have Faculty of
will
we're going to talk about this more next
class you have the capacity to choose
things stop thinking about Enoch or now
make yourself stop who succeeded in
anyone who's still stuck with the
unicorn in their head now think about a
giraffe can you do that who's thinking
about a giraffe now you chose to do that
right you did it because I I told you to
but if you know if you wanted to be
perverse you said whatever dr. Sandler
says
do that I'm gonna do something else I'm
gonna think of a rhinoceros instead well
that would be your choice you can make
yourself do that you with your will you
can bring things to mind you can make
yourself think about things you can
force yourself to understand things you
can also use your will to move your body
you know we like to raise my hand right
now and then of course you have
influence or I understand all of these
are what you are all of these are you
all these functions together all these
are modes of thought now these are all
places that we could get things from so
let's think about our ideas now some
ideas we we think that we got from
external sources you all are familiar
with the idea of the pain right some of
you may be in pain right now if you're
sick where did you get that idea
at the beginning because you started out
as a babies you know screaming and then
people did things to shut you up
right because you were in pain of one
form or another you felt it was
something from we think from the outside
affecting you or you know could have
been internal but it could've been your
body as we get older you manage because
these are coming to you we think from
the outside what about other ideas well
some ideas we make up ourselves like
what's a flavor of gum that he hasn't
been invented yet do you think of
anything when I was a kid there there
was a lot of flavors of government
suddenly they started making all sorts
of things you could have like blue
raspberry gum we thought that was really
great now there's like you know you walk
into a grocery store different kinds of
gum
what's a flavor you wouldn't make
because you think that would be terrible
to do dirt flavored gum okay perfect
just come home from the gum but you can
imagine that you just did actually and
what did you do you combine two things
the sensation of like what dirt taste
like which is not pleasant I hope and
then chewing gum you combined ideas
where did that idea come from you you
created it other ideas might be
implanted in us maybe they were there
from the start and the card actually
thinks that there are a lot of ideas
that that we were sort of born with now
why do we believe that we have ideas of
things that actually correspond to real
things outside of our mind why do we
believe that other things exist besides
ourselves
again can we be absolutely sure of that
Descartes thinks at this point we can't
and this is where he's going to talk
about God's existence
with pretty much anything else you could
think of that you could say well maybe I
made up that idea maybe that idea really
came from me it doesn't correspond to
anything outside of my son outside of
this thinking thing but what about the
idea of God well what does that idea
include let's think about that for now
what does take Kurt's idea of God yeah
it's a very metaphysical concept of God
does he have a white beard
yes or no
just a card saying the meditations I'm
thinking of God I'm thinking of the guy
in the sky with a white beard sitting on
a cloud
you remember running across that
anywhere why not why doesn't he talk
about God that way just be sort of a
sense right I mean most of you don't
think of God broader conception whether
you believe God exists or not hopefully
have a broader conception that that just
that what does he think guys
he's also said at one point he says that
thank you God
includes guys of substance thanks we've
got guys like us God exists God can have
different attributes a substance and I
had what sort of internal we don't even
really need to bother with eternal at
this plant infinite eternal independent
all-knowing all-powerful and by which I
myself and every other thing that exists
if there be such things were created it
says these properties are so great and
excellent the more attentively I
consider them the less I feel persuaded
that the idea I have of them owes its
origin to myself alone and there's two
other things that go into his eye
important one is supremely perfect right
and the other one is oh and he's not
going to talk about the goodness of God
very much yeah this portion of the tax
let's put them up later on and that's
going to be very very important think
back to the an something we talked about
powers this is taking a sort of a little
detour over this is gonna get you to
show you where we're going if God is
Allgood
could God be a deceiver yes or no can
you think of any cases where it could be
good to deceive somebody maybe you know
maybe if somebody wants to shoot
themself and you know I tell them well I
could do that you're gonna get out
automatically go to hell and that's
gonna be worse than then you know
whatever your enduring right now but I
don't know that that's actually the case
I would be deceiving them wouldn't I
maybe that would be a good reason to
deceive somebody could God do something
like that
first off you wouldn't need to right
he's all-powerful he can do whatever he
wants
it's usually a sign of weakness
or a lack or being imperfect or lacking
goodness to be a deceiver
so if God's not a deceiver that means
that we can count on things actually
being the way they think that they are
provided we're careful we're going to
talk more about that next class when it
gets to meditation for we're gonna look
more at this infinite perfect so again
let's think about these ideas
you can all think of something infinite
right where did you get that idea from
did it come from
from the outside world have you ever
seen anything infinite which seems look
some things maybe some of you have seen
some things that are kind of like how
many under the ocean or at least in one
of the Great Lakes
you've looked out you know you can look
you can't see the other Shore you just
see the horizon you see waves as far as
as far as you go
that might be like sort of a picture of
infinity if you try to wrap your head
around it and thinking about all those
waves and all those movements it almost
makes you can't feel like a sense of
vertigo doesn't you trying to think of
that but that's not yet infinite all
right just the Great Lakes only contains
so much water right you could put a
number on it I don't know what the
number is but apparently it's something
like 25% of the world's fresh water is a
nice Great Lakes which is good for us
around here what about the world's
oceans those are bigger right there are
those infinite there's a given number
that we could assign to it so you
haven't seen something into that could
that notion have come from you by you
know working with your imagination of
putting ideas together or could it have
come from you to yourself maybe you're
in do you think you are and you're that
you're actually going limit and just
like I am
there's a lot of things we can't do
the very fact that for instance right
now you don't know exactly what the
heart says in every single you know
point in his in his book means that
you're finite the fact that you probably
haven't read
who are gonna read later in the semester
that means your finite if you were
infinite you could major in every single
subject that will actually you wouldn't
need to major in a subject you wouldn't
have to go to school you'd already know
everything
wouldn't you so you're not getting that
idea of infinity from yourself you're
not getting it from the outside world
where is it coming from that you have an
idea but because you understand this
right God is an infinite supremely
perfect all going to substance that make
sense to you you may not believe that
such a thing exists but you can you can
have these think of it where's that
coming from
let's think about perfection - have you
ever experienced perfection maybe a
perfect cupcake perfect cup of coffee
perfect day heaven perfect song
he's in a perfect piece of chalk I don't
even know what a perfect piece of chalk
would be I don't know what go into
making a piece of chalk particularly
great so I certainly can't think of what
would make it perfect
is there a perfect number I don't know
well okay so where are we getting this
ideas from this is where did part starts
introducing some some terminology that
it's really important to be clear about
because otherwise it won't make sense to
put that in your it talks about two
things one is positive factor right and
the other one is tines or modes of
reality so let's let's think about the
easier one to raise kwasind effect right
we've talked about cause and effect
before you know here's well here's the
occurrence meditations what is the cause
of this you could you know come up with
a whole bunch of causes what's the most
immediate cause of this this book
actually being then you could think of
right off the bat
how did it get here in the class you
brought it right so I'm the cause of it
being physically here in front of you
right now how did it come to be in a
broader sense what do you know about
books where do they come myself looking
from the books well where'd the book
store get it right how did this come to
be
somebody wrote it
that's actually further out in the
process but we can jump right to that I
mean the you know printing presses and
and all that but you have somebody wrote
this so Descartes wrote this book
somebody actually edited this is this is
the Descartes version that has the the
French which he didn't write it by the
way the current Ronit laughing even
though he's a French guy and then
somebody else translated his Latin into
French because he didn't think his
French was you know really that debt
that great and then he looked at the
translation said yeah that that looks
okay so the Curtin is responsible for
this this book existing he's the cause
of it right now I need to point along
the way if we're thinking about reality
the cause has to have at least as much
or more
the guy Rene Descartes was in some sense
more real than the words on this page
because those came from him right just
like it when you're you're writing your
papers do you want me to take your paper
as being in some way more real than you
your paper belongs to you right it's a
reflection of you it's not like the
paper made you you make the paper you
write the paper
similarly anything else that we can say
with cause and effect the cause is in
some way more real than the effect that
comes from it has to have more reality
where would be something with the same
amount of reality well you don't think
about your parents right they're equally
real as you are or at least they were
when when you were conceived you know
and they they were human beings you're a
human being if you have kids your kids
are going to be equally real as you
they're not gonna be more real or less
real they're gonna be the same kind of
thing in school but things like this are
in some sense less less real they have
less reality a lesser degree
ontologically they're not as as great
just like the words that I'm speaking
right now and coming from me I'm the
cause of them and in some way they're
not as as good not as real not as true
not as whatever you want to say as me if
you have an idea for instance again I
hold this book up you don't actually
know what's in this maybe maybe it's not
really words maybe I use this too you
know
some people have to take the Bible and
they cut out things bless you they put
their cash when they're gone or their
their stash of whatever it is they want
to hide if they have done that with this
you know if you're going to actually
know all you have is a sense impression
in your mind and when you leave this
classroom you'll remember this as part
of the lecture today but it will just be
sort of a you know a bunch of sensitive
put together in your memory that's
what's real in this deception book right
the image in your mind this browses
right because you look at it you see
certain characteristics matter of fact
believe it was a hand this around you
can know now you're actually feeling it
you're adding more sense characteristics
to it but your sensation of it is less
real than that is your idea of all of
you came in from the outside right so
you it was raining
when you okay remember that rate that
memory is an effect of the real rain
that you encountered that rain is more
real than the image in your mind do you
remember back to Plato right they don't
have kind of a similar idea about images
that you know copies are not as real as
the things that they're copied from okay
well the things in your mind are copies
aren't they if a copy of that book
that's being passed around you have a
copy of all sorts of things you have a
copy of this you know who corduroy
blazer that I'm wearing right now in
your mind you have a copy of words on
the truck or
the chalkboard itself so that gets us to
a closet effect now let's think about
and distinction here is between what he
calls objective reality and what he
calls formal reality what objective
reality is it's the reality that
something has in your mind has an idea
that's that's kind of hard to wrap your
head around so I'm gonna stay together
objective reality is the reality that
something has in your mind as 19 so if
you think about that book that's going
around all right
not every but not everyone can see it
right now certainly and not all of you
can be touching it right now
experiencing that but those of you who
have seen it that book exists in your
minds but it exists in your mind with
the reality of an idea let's say we burn
this book now right does the book exist
anymore
if we burn it doesn't exist in reality
right but it still exists in your mind
doesn't it there's other things that
only exist in your mind like the unive
the blue unicorn that then hates you
that we talked about earlier or the
purple unicorn who who loves you those
who only have objective reality they
don't have formal real the formal
reality is actually existing outside
your mind somewhere else what does this
sound like to you does this bring back
anything that we did it earlier this
semester when we started talking about
medieval philosophers this distinction
about being real in the mind and being
real outside of the mind
reality this remind you of anybody give
you a hint somebody where you talked
about two and a half weeks ago can't
stop all right what was what was the
similarity there the ants was an
argument about God's existence right
and he said God could just exist in the
mind when you called that in the
understanding or he could exist in
reality outside of the mind
well the card is doing something very
similar here so Diggs heart is going to
say let's think about this idea of God
and listen dear God exist in your mind
along with a whole bunch of others right
your mind is cluttered like like a whole
junk drawer with a million different
ideas but this idea is kind of unique
right this idea is of something that is
infinite perfect as an idea this this
idea has the greatest reality what kind
of reality
objective now remember a clause can only
you can only have a clause for something
if that clause is greater or at least
has the same amount of reality yeah is
the thing that's its effect so what
about this idea this is like the best
idea you could possibly have the
greatest idea what could its cause be
could it be me no because I don't there
must be some clause for this effect in
my mind what could it be
it can't be meaning it can't be anything
that I've observed in the world that I
haven't used to so what could it be
well it must be something else that is
infinite perfect and has all the other
qualities that we attribute to God
maybe it's not God right maybe it's
something else well then that would be
God I mean that's what we mean by
existing and being infinite and perfect
and all that now notice this is a little
bit different than an Psalms proof the
an Psalms proof had to do with you know
to take the idea of God and they sort of
explored the idea and pact with it what
it must mean and all that this is saying
if we have ideas in our mind those ideas
had to come from somewhere and the idea
the thing that it came from has to have
at least as much reality as the idea
does and this idea has the greatest
degree of reality possible so it must
have come from something that actually
has the greatest degree of reality
possible the only thing that could
possibly satisfy that description is
what
what could it be
you think of anything else that's
infinite and perfect since what people
call God
if you can't then elaborate I must exist
if you could think of something else you
could you could get off the hook here
now this is one way to try to argue for
God's existence and dick hurt actually
ends up staying yeah you know God wants
to put this idea of himself itself or
whatever you want to call it into me
that must be part of my thank you that
must be part of my very being so this is
kind of like an Psalms argument it's
kind of hard to say exactly what kind of
argument it is because it deals with
cause and effect a lot of people want to
call this a cosmological article like
Thomas Aquinas is arguments right saying
you can't you know have an infinite
regress or those sorts of things not a
lot of people want to see this as a
logical argument Descartes later on in
meditation v will actually make it a
amount illogical are so let's look at
that one next and then if we have time
well look at me
so now remember ontological arguments
they work by taking the idea of God and
then somehow unpacking or pulling it all
the day the idea open or working with
them and saying AHA that that thing must
exist it must be something like that if
we want to take the current argument and
boil it down to sort of its absolute its
simplest form it would be something like
this of a is a supremely perfect being
and existence is a perfection it's
better to exist that not to exist
anybody here want to not exist
no anybody here want their money in
their pocket not to exist with a credit
card whatever it is that you have you
prefer those things to exist right
better for those things to exist and not
to exist really the only things that you
don't want to exist are panthans
right you prefer your pain not to exist
or if you really hate somebody the
Aristotle says one way to define hatred
is the
yet somebody else not exists you know
it'll be wiped off the face of the earth
when it comes good things to exist is a
perfection well therefore God must exist
now the card says not everybody's going
to blackness because doesn't this seem a
little fishy do I have the idea of God
the idea is a supremely perfect being
existence is a perfection so you know
the idea being that has every single
perfection that includes existence so
God must exist Descartes says yeah okay
this looks sophistical that means that
it looks like an argument that's trying
to trick you
and he thinks that something stands in
the way of seeing it right away and
here's the way to act
so with everything else that we
experience you can distinguish between
its essence what it is he had its
existence so we'll use an object like
for instance right this pen has a
certain essence certain form to it you
can define it we can all point to it and
say pen nobody looks at this and says
ruler or a kitty cat or anything like
that those are other kinds of beings
right this is a kind of being does this
have to exist this probably didn't exist
until a couple of years ago
I'm going to bet that it's only a few
years old and once it's no longer abused
I'm going to throw it out and it'll be
destroyed rolling down into its
component parts I don't necessarily
exist I could have easily not have
existed I'm you know the product of two
people getting together one time and one
time only
and that could have easily not happened
does that mean that you know another
doctor saying they would have popped up
somewhere else God any one of us could
not exist any of these chairs desks the
tiles on the floor the pieces of Shawn
all those things are contingent so we're
used to thinking about things as here's
what the thing is
and then here's whether it exists or not
God is one of those kind of things that
curve is saying where the what it is
includes existing we're not used to
thinking in those sort of terms we're
not used to thinking about necessary
beings so our way or our habits lead us
to saying ah this isn't a good argument
because we're not thinking in this case
of God we're thinking of other things
so he says what we're doing there is
we're actually looking at things the
wrong way the Kirk says that existence
in essence forgot or sort of like
valiant mountain they go together right
and it's not like you know chocolate and
peanut butter and Reese's peanut butter
cups that those don't have to go
together right you can have the
chocolate by itself you can have the
peanut butter by itself they've recently
started showing ads where just like when
I was a kid that had these people that
run together and you got your chocolate
in my peanut butter
you got your peanut butter in my
chocolate right that didn't have to
happen but if you have a mountain the
mountain has to have a valley right and
if you have a valley bless you you don't
have a family without having a mountain
well existence and assets are like that
for God Descartes says now do you see
any any way to defeat that any way you
might object to that do you have to have
mountains and valleys could you have a
world that doesn't have any mountains
and valleys yeah so the mere fact that
if you start thinking about mountain you
also have to think of valleys doesn't
mean that just because you think of God
and what God would be that God has tab
automatically exists
that's what de Descartes says is a
possible objection and Dickert says yeah
I admit the fact that I can't conceive
amount without a valley means that only
if there's a mountain there has to be
family along with it but what's the
along with it in God's case its
existence it's to actually exist to be
real so from the fact that I he says
from the fact that cannot conceive God
without existence it follows that
existence is inseparable from God and
that he really exists and he deals with
another objection to the other objection
is isn't this kind of
taking your thought as sort of imposing
order or existence or whatever you want
to say and on reality so because you
think something is the way it is so
because you have this idea in your mind
therefore boom did now exists out there
and we saw this problem danced on to
write an Psalms proof kind of made it
look like well I just have to have the
idea and now the idea exists does that
work with anything else
imagine a 10 foot long chocolate bar
does that have to exist because you
think of it I mean it could exist but I
think it's something that couldn't be
automatic this well I'm gonna exist in
your mind but does the thought of an
existing your mind sort of projected on
intuitive reality that's the worry about
this because you know you can have the
thought of your mind if you don't
believe in God you can at least say okay
if there was a God even be like this but
I don't think there is right then you're
saying it's just in your mind
Descartes is say once it's in there you
and you adequately understanding I did
you see that it has to include existence
but what you're doing there is just
recognizing something that already does
exist out of your mind because of the
way it's made your mind you're able to
to grasp that so again this is kind of
similar to an some similar process not
just in carrying out the proof but in
explaining why somebody else might find
the proof unconvincing Descartes is a
very famous advocate of the ontological
argument probably the strongest
proponent of it since ants alms time his
version is a bit different than in
science right what a dance mom say God
was he didn't say God is a supremely
perfect being
he said I'm saying I'm not saying God is
a supremely perfect being I'm calling
God what will happen they have much do
you remember the rest of that
greater can be thought right that's a
different idea than supremely perfect
via the card is actually going to a
place that handsome chose not to go he's
using a different idea and songs ideas
kind of a fun de cartes idea is a more
positive idea handsome didn't think that
would work by the way again so I
wouldn't buy dessert
Descartes does and whether we agree with
Descartes or not it's going to be
important for us to see where he goes
with this at this point it's not going
to be whether God exists or not because
they cart you know believes themselves
to improve it it's whether God could
actually be a deceiver
remember the whole goal of this is not
just to decide where the guy exists the
cards never going to make any more use
of God once he's once he's proven his
existence and gotten him to not be
deceiver it's going to be whether we can
trust reality as we see it whether we
can trust my own experience whether we
can trust science whether we can trust
our own minds whether we can trust logic
and being able to trust that there's a
god out there that created everything
and is not a deceiver so didn't set
things up just to screw with us like an
evil demon would that's going to be an
integral part of Descartes philosophy so
the last thing I'm going to say is that
if we go back to meditation one the
current says something that that some
people take to be a proof of God's
existence he says I could have become to
be in a couple ways how did I myself as
a being it's a thinking thing how did it
come to exist so
what's one possibility yeah what are
some other possibilities we can look at
our own culture for this if you don't
believe in God how do you think you got
here there's a human being yeah people
will say things like evolution Descartes
instead says chance or fate or sex
interlocking
how does evolution action how's it
supposed to work right well there's all
these different clauses and effects and
they're all connected to each other so
you know we find out for instance that
what's what's an example why do we walk
around like this right not like eight
men you know like monkeys or knaves well
there was an evolutionary usefulness to
standing erect and what was that they
think because it's not actually good for
your back stand up like this this is
actually better for animals to be
hunched over dogs don't have a lot of
back problems for the most part except
you know inbred dogs not a lot of
gorillas have back problems what
advantage of this give us
two things really er we can see a lot
farther right so you can see the lion
coming along weighs a lot before it eats
you
there's no the gorilla doesn't see it
until it's right on top of them and the
other thing was what are these good for
just about everything right this is what
this and you know the big little grain
and then of course the capacity to speak
that's what made us human we're the tool
using a tool producing creature yeah I
know you know other monkeys but not
monkeys apes will you know stick a stick
into the termite thing and pull the
termites out that's kind of like using a
tool but they don't they don't make
iPhones so that would be like you know
sort of interlocking Colossus how does
evolution actually work chance right if
we were just going by just straight-out
evolution and not using medicine or
anything most of us would be dead by how
because most of us you know would have
to succumb to some childhood sickness or
you know there was something about our
genetic makeup that wouldn't work like
my ankle's overpronate that means the
lion would have got me or you know I
wear glasses would have been passing my
genes on because it's hard to throw that
spear and you know kill whatever it is
that you're going to get if you can't
see that at the back of the room so a
chance plays a role they don't think
with evolution that it's faint although
you could think of you know some sort of
cosmic thing that sort of these are all
possibilities now if here's where the
something like an argument for God's
existence comes to predict hurt is all
about resolving doubt being able to be
certain about things if I was created by
God then I could have a chance of
figuring everything out because I would
have structured the universe and
structured me in such a way that I would
be able to do that right provided he's
not like I screw with you Pentagon just
make people and you know set them up it
to fail the right but he's a good guy it
would be possible for the universe and
for the human being
to be what we call intelligible to be
understandable but if it's chance what
then if we're just the product of things
coming together in certain ways is there
any necessity that we actually figure
out what's what can we not be to see you
there isn't I mean it could turn out
that but maybe we won't there's no you
know there's no purpose if there's a
purpose behind it but it's not it's not
God so it's not something all good
something that doesn't care about giving
the aims are we likely to actually be
able to figure everything out it all
depends on what fate would have decided
we have no way of knowing what fateful
sign right because there's a whole bunch
of clauses all coming together take you
know just the right way at the right
time does that hold out a lot of
possibility that we could ever truly
know what we are what the world is
what's true what's false
not much this is actually and I'm not
saying that this is a good argument for
God is God's existence but people do
make this kind of argument they say it's
all just evolution how could you even
know if evolution is true maybe worse
you know set up in such a way that we're
deceived even about them well there is
there's something to be said that's
considered by some people to be an
argument for God's existence that you
can find in Descartes more by French
scholars in America and our English
dollars but the ones that are really
important are the third meditation and
the fifth meditation so next class we're
going to pick up at the fourth
meditation and see what we what mileage
we get out of assuming that God exists
I'll see all of you let me